I have two kids you have two kids do you
have two daughters I do yeah five and
two okay what are they into now what
stage are they at there are very
specific stages when you have kids um
well the small one now is into repeating
words and hers his sentences she learned
a sentence which is daddy are you busy
that's all she says over and over to
anybody right : are you busy like you
just ask anybody that's nice
yeah and the big one is into princesses
yep princesses Liebig my daughter's
princess face is going on and on and it
hasn't stopped
no has not stopped okay she's 34 years
old yeah it's sort of tough the princess
you know phase cuz you know I like
playing with dolls and all that stuff
but you know there's the names and
they're all you know you like playing
with dolls
no but they get really into the details
of the fairy world and the princesses
right and they want you to say it like
it is in the movie and I'm like how
about you know let's mix it up a little
bit and like no I they wouldn't do that
so I read when I read the stories you
know like there's a princess story or
whatever and I always I read it I read
it I read it and then at the end I
change it what do you do well instead of
like a magic enchanted kiss in the
forest that makes the girl happy I'm
like and then she went to the forest and
she opened up a string of successful dry
cleaners
and that works I can see a child really
not being happy with that he does not
love it at night sweetie daddy that's
not it she kisses the princess in the
forest my way is more profitable yeah
she became